[Music]
paleoanthropologist shook up the world
of early human research when they
determined that a homo sapiens skull
from morocco is three hundred thousand
years old that's a hundred thousand
years older than any past find
biologists made a big advance in editing
DNA and RNA developing techniques to
transform one nucleotide base into
another at a precise point a team in
China used a version of the technique to
correct a point mutation in a human
embryo a new fda-approved drug reflects
a long-awaited shift from treating
cancers based on their origins to one
grounded in tumor biology the drug is
designed to treat advanced solid tumors
that have a specific genetic defect no
matter where in the body the cancer
arose this year biologists posted a
record number of preprints papers that
have not yet been peer-reviewed biology
appears to be following physics where
preprints have changed the culture of
communicating results scientists
collected the oldest ice core ever
it's 2.7 million years old and came from
a desolate region of Antarctica it
shatters the record by 1.7 million years
bubbles trapped in the ice by travillian
house gas levels at the start of the Ice
Age
physicists used a detector the size of a
milk jug to observe neutrinos pinging
off atomic nuclei in a way never seen
before the achievement confirms a
forty-year-old prediction and it opens
the way for portable detectors that can
spot these elusive particles gene
researchers had a dramatic success with
a new treatment for a neuromuscular
disease usually it kills infants but the
small trial demonstrated the power of a
new way of ferrying genetic cargo across
the blood-brain barrier wildlife
scientists identified a new species of
orangutans on the Indonesian island of
Sumatra it's the first grade age species
to be discovered
since the bonobo but with just 800
individuals this species is imperiled
it's been a banner year for
cryo-electron microscopy it's a
technique that allows scientists to
determine the structures of complex
molecules as they interact the arrival
of new computer software is providing
fresh insights into many of life's key
molecules and the tools are fast
reshaping the field of structural
biology and now the breakthrough of the
year
for the first time astronomers were able
to fully observe a collision of two
neutron stars one of the most violent
events in the cosmos first they spotted
gravitational waves ripples in
space-time then they trained multiple
telescopes on their source to witness a
spectacular burst of radiation that
contained answers to some long-standing
cosmic mysteries and opening a new era
in astronomy
[Music]